this program is brought to you by Emory
University
fundamentally the the drugs that we use
today are are very similar to the drugs
that we've used since the 1980s 1983 was
the the drug the drug that
revolutionized transplantation
cyclosporine was introduced since then
that class of drugs another drug very
similar to it have been the cornerstone
the foundation of immunosuppression so
it's been since 1983 since we've had a
new drug that has formed the foundation
of transplant preventing transplant
rejection
rejection is caused by an immune
response an immune reaction against the
transplant and when we when we reject an
organ we have to recognize it as foreign
and then we get these other signals
co-stimulatory signals that turn on the
immune system what ballot asif does is
block those co-stimulatory or second
signals and therefore it aborts the
rejection response
you
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University